Hello!
MY DRUNK KITCHEN: Best Friends PHO-ever (parody) // Grace Helbig
Booboop
We should want my friends videos more regularly it looks beautiful
Mmmmm
What on my face already!?
Remember Iman?
Yes? Yes?
*laughing*
This week on My Drunk Kitchen we are in place of Hannah
We're doing a secret my drunk kitchen that she doesn't even know about
Because we want to talk about her TV show we're very excited for. This is an episode a parody episode of my drunk kitchen in
Honor of I heart food Hannah Hart's new food Network television show it's coming out in a week
So go ahead and set your dVRs bitches. Today
We thought it would be fun because we have a lot of memories attached with our girl
Hannah with the food fuck because one of the things that we all commiserate on is when
Whenever we've all three gotten really really drunk together never happened never next morning
We all wants to kind of cleanse our sins, so we created our
Interpersonal holiday called Super Bowl Sunday, yeah, where we go and we eat Pho hungover as a means to heal ourselves
Pho makes me shit? Which is a great way to say like really cleans, okay? I?
Just assumed that I've drank so much play before that so I have diarrhea. Neither one of us have made Pho before so...
Wwhich I think is in line with how Hannah operates on my drunk kitchen
We are not going to use regular pasta. However,. we are going to use pasta zero which is a precooked pasta
made out of
some various things that's already cooked
I spilled my entire drink on myself in the background while you're explaining that hahaha
This is Mamrie knows how to cook and I'm a sous chef
What are we doing first figuring out how to turn this on it's already warm. Oh my God it says caution hot
I just keep high-fiving it like a child laughing. This is heating up. There's some crazy-ass spices in this dish
What kind of spices we should how about anything before? We did this where we're going to toast some spices
Let's put in a few whole clove.
Oh, we're just when I'm straight in?! We're going to toast it and then add the liquid. Oh. We're so close to the
Premiere of Hannah Hart's new show on the food Network. I'll take it. Now we've got star anise
I put in three of these what is that they look like dehydrated starfish shit
it imparts a licorice light flavor with a note of sweetness perfect for pho. Hannah is a star yes, and
Anis has an aunt she's man oh
Then our third one. We have a whole cinnamon stick. We didn't realize before coming to this office that hannah already has a whole
cinnamon sticks here. You guys probably all knew that because you've kept up with your videos as of late
We're good friends only need to be I think she's got a future
She should really stick with it, and if you don't watch it. That's a sin a-mon, Iman the model is not a huge fan
So get in it smell it it smells like Christmas
It doesn't smell so weird that this is what Pho is. You'll see ah is a lot like friendship
We consider ourselves, best friends pho-ever
Because it is there for you when you've done something bad and then it also
It always helps you get the shit out of you. Yeah in my case. Because it might be fo Pho... fee fie fo fa
Doesn't Hannah rap? This carrot onesie. Carrot Carrot onesie. Carrot Carrot onesie .
Oh, I'm ready to get to the root of this don't want to vegetate - Ludacris that don't need to add to date your butt
Is in your nature and like it's good people? I'm studious. Okay? Now. We're going to throw in some fresher stuff
It says some garlic so what I'm gonna do do a dress throw in that
But you don't take this
No
Because you strain it to get all this you don't want to bite on a star anise,   I don't have dental insurance
You don't have health insurance
It's one little dab
That's like life
We just put a bunch of things into your person and then hopefully throughout the years you just strain out all the good
That is very, Hannah-esque thing. I don't know. Wow that is fragrant as fuck! The garlic or the ginger? You!
We're going to just chop up some ginger
We're gonna put some broth in some water
And then we're gonna let that simmer simmer simmer we're going to do to this broth what we do to Hannah
Strain it. That's true
I'm so proud of her! Mamrie is obsessed the food network and the fact that our best friend has a show on it like
she's
Containing excitement last night. I watched just on my own volition
Five episodes beat Bobby flay. Do I look prettier? So then I'm going to put in a quarter of an onion.
Now it's starting to smell more like the smell that I associate with Pho
That's a positive sign. Who knows   how to smell.  Here is the funniest thing about our relationship with Hannah
You both pun. Yeah
But hannah accuses you have not knowing what a pun is... she gives me a pun for my money. You kidding
I got no money. So now I'm going to add
Some veggie broth to the pool to the pot
I'm going to add wine to Mamrie's glass. All around whoa this smells amazing already now
I'm going to add some water. I filled it like half way
I'm going to do one part water to two parts broth. I have no idea what I'm doing
It's like one part hannah two parts dumbasses. BURP
Does Hannah burp on her show? No, Hannah doesn't like like bodily functions. That's a blows my mind
We've done this Fart soundboard challenge a few times now a couple...twice
I forget every time that she does not find farts as hilarious as we do
many, many fart  noises... adn then laughter
Also, side note. We're using low sodium broth. You know the three of us have what some might call a really solid sisterhood
But today we have a brotherhood okay?
Okay, if you want to come over and eat some pho and pay me for sex. I got a brothel
That's just me advertising ... that's a Craig's list advertisement spoken out loud. You guys, It's Bubblin. It's fucking looking beautiful
Get in there snif it Helbig. I can smell it from here. get in there though! Do we look majestic??
I don't think it reads. We just watched hannah's video for making a souffle, and it works well people
They may be a souffle is hard. I just may want drunk. So we're very proud of her good job. Hannah
Yep, that's all brand for this type of video.
Cheers! Is there any Tequila in here? Yeah, we have coffee Tequila! Hannah. This is for you
Nothing goes better with pho than coffee tequila. We couldn't find shot glasses, so I hope you give hannah show a shot you'll be coffee-ing
From laughter because she's so charming it'll measure up. Oh
I have cavity yes. I have cavities.
Here we are with the final outcome of the food, but you don't know anything about this yet
You can learn all about how we finish this Harto inspired meal over at Mamrie's, channel
Go check it out because things got drunker and more delicious dare I say?That bite was too hot
I just looked insane that entire time you were talking. If you ever want to know what Mamrie's Channel is like
she just gave you a very very deep insight into it.
Come on over I'll welcome you with open arms like a sweet southern mom on a front porch. She calls her cooter arms
Hahahaha! Sweet southern cooter
This is really good. I'm not just saying it because we have collectively drank a bottle of wine and a bottle of vodka
No, my taste doesn't change except in men when I'm drunk
Boo-boop